this is tommy and jp from in camera who
are a youtube channel and effects house
that make effect for real
and we're gonna do a fire stunt we are
but we ourselves are not going to
conduct this stunt we've got a specific
fire team in to do it because that's
just what they do do not try this
anywhere
hey feeling a bit nervous three
two
one
do you know what you've signed up for
put it out this is a very strange
feeling
there's no going back now absolutely tom
scott's idea yes hold your breath ignite
him
bam three two one action
[Music]
when you go you're probably just gonna
want to go straight away so
the fake tom scott video so the sort of
premise is that we have uh jp and tommy
from in camera have come to show tom
scott some pyrotechnics
uh a spark goes off which we've rigged
they go to investigate tom has a leaky
can of a flammable liquid which he puts
down a second spot goes off which
ignites tom
tom comes up with his arm on fire
realizes it shakes are trying to put it
out comes running up the table
through the set past the casting crew
and then we'll collapse roughly where
i'm standing where our very expert
safety team will put him out nice and
safely
thank you for bringing all the the
pyrotechnics and and buttons and things
along i know you're not going to be the
actual person like lighting me up here
no but
what have you brought what's what's the
plot we're doing here well so yeah we're
kind of setting up the kind of the gag
we're doing the setup essentially um and
so we've got a couple of things we want
to show you uh how we make some
miniature pyrotechnics but also to lead
us into
the burn
uh we've brought some just very again
quite simple little spark kits which we
remote trigger
um with something like this which uh
looks you know i mean who doesn't want
that it's the greatest remote
controllers ever and you turn it on with
a key with an actual key
come on oh that looks like a problem
that looks like something you've made
for your channel
there's actually just someone on an ipad
in the back but you want to go
i'm not sure i believe that's a real i
know i know i understand but it is
you'll have to trust us all right um and
then that sends a little
uh a signal to this it sounds like a
receiver it looks like a prop it looks
like something out of a sci-fi show but
it's literally so that's literally made
so that people can wear it as costumes
so they can literally kind of have it on
there if you can use them for squibs
bullet hits things like that
so they could either hide that within a
costume or just on the belt around the
back if you can't see it and so but
essentially it's just a it's a remote
transmitter receiver type situation so
this can just trigger any number of
little things whatever they might be and
in today's case that's going to be some
little sparks yes so we're setting up
the the fake video here we're doing the
fake introduction yes we needed to come
up with some sort of ignition basically
yeah yeah and fuel which we haven't
brought something is going to go
deliberately wrong in the background
very well so so we're just establishing
the audience that you are in fact
competent and this is not us
yeah well this is it there's a weird
metal level i know we had to put this
scene together so how can we do this so
that something goes wrong but it's not
looking like our fault because we're
idiots like yeah that's that was the
balance we the tightrope we had to we
still look like it is oh yeah we still
look like idiots we had to accept that
to a certain degree um but yes so those
are our kind of little couple of little
tricks that we've brought along that
enable us to get into this
serious business of setting you on fire
yeah why do you want to be set on fire
tom
i
have seen the stunt in person a couple
of times at like um
i can't things like the you know
universal studios we'll do the live
stunt show and we'll show off a burn
and i realize that most people's
reaction to that is like oh that's
that's a that's a starship and my
reaction was like oh i want to do that
wow that's i absolutely want to do that
okay
[Music]
are you happy with this today
yeah i mean this was my idea i'm not
being not being pressured into this good
um basically we're gonna go through the
safety procedures later we're gonna make
sure you're happy we're gonna rehearse
rehearse rehearse rehearsal rehearse
then rehearse again i'll go through all
the strategy procedures again and then
your arm's gonna be set on fire here
your lower back and legs it will be
quite warm any problems let me know and
we'll abort so
it's gonna be
arm yep leg lower back and presumably
the flames go up from there yeah right
we will do some testing so you can see
it so you can see where the flames are
and the movement of the flames because
obviously if you're moving around the
flame's gonna be traveling either side
just for you
right okay um and that's basically it i
should be feeling cold all the way
through you shouldn't feel heat
penetrating if you feel heat penetrating
then we have to get your colors off very
very fast but that shouldn't happen
i'm just pre-warning you just in case
because we're playing with fire no no
that's that's worth knowing like i would
have assumed that i will feel i will
feel radiant heat on me you will fail
really raining hate on your face back in
your neck but try to avoid it keep your
face away from it as you can see the
flames traveling and you don't want to
do two bigger movements because the
flame's gonna travel and hit you in the
face
okay right good this is
sounds really bizarre
but when flames hit you in the face it's
like being punched it's that powerful
right it's really really really hard it
will hit you and you'll feel like
someone's just hit you straight on the
nose so you want to avoid that totally
100 that feels like first person
experience there yeah
how much fire stuff have you done
i've probably been set on fire fully
about
15 20 times i've had an arm set on fire
i've had my head set on fire
i've been on fire thrown through
explosions um i did a full fire job and
got spout sideways onto the floor um and
that was self-detonating that'd hold the
detonate myself hit it and get thrown
through an explosion that was quite
gnarly
so that is black powder or no this is a
sveltean powder which is a derivative of
a petronium process
uh it's a very fine powder and once it's
uh
projected into the air and has enough
oxygen
uh amongst its particles will ignite in
the air and self burn and create a nice
looking hollywood style
fireball right okay the advantage of
using these powders is because they're
not liquid we're not going to get any of
the
residual burning uh fluids and things
like that that can be quite hazardous
all right
so this is the test for whatever's i'm
going to be standing here with
well with the the completely fake and
slightly freaking out our safety team
flammable liquid cannon this is the one
thing that definitely does not have
anything in it yeah i'm gonna be
standing here and this is gonna go off
behind me yeah okay so this that yeah it
makes me twitch as well
that's weird um so we're just gonna do a
quick initial test on this now uh so if
i get you to step back just a couple of
steps
how much here oh that's more okay i'll
be closer than that
okay
so this
okay oh i only just worked so that
you've got a bellows you push that air
goes under
from into the into the block that's
right so effectively
we
projecting the powder in the air and
when it's within the air it's by this
point it's started its ignition
and continue our fireball all right
okay is this gonna be loud it won't be
loud so you get a nice woof deep sound
okay and hopefully a nice impressive
looking fireball
so we'll be firing in three
two
one
oh
nice smoke ring that's lovely
it gives that kind of hollywood rich
orangey black yeah kind of rolling
fireball and it's great for miniature
effects because
as you saw there's no residual burning
it's not that's a burning gunpowder no
no
we're getting a test spark to kick off
now that jp is going to fire before we
go for a real tech jp the floor is yours
thank you
and we are testifying in three two one
there you go louder than expected right
i
i was expecting less than that i i have
a little after image there i didn't want
to look directly at that
you're okay
yeah that was actually less than i
expected
do you know what you signed up for when
you picked the when you took the
direction
cool all right sparks working we're good
to go team uh can we have everyone
rolling up please
the whole day has been building up to
this afternoon we did the rest of the
scene this morning um but right now is
the main event we're just about to get
tom all gelled up and ready to go we're
all we're all gathered and all ready
yep we're going to get you changed now
we're going to change your costume we're
going to wear 100 cotton because
obviously that's flame retardant and
we're going to put some fireproof
underwear underneath to make sure you
don't burn are you happy yeah are you
ready
i'm ready
let's go then
ready for this
oh okay there's there's no preamble to
that just
so what is this stuff i know it's this
is a fire gel okay i'm actually using it
more as a lubricant you've got to get
this on okay okay
well that's deeply unpleasant
and the good news is it's it's the right
size for me perfect but that is that's
that's a lot of goo good
the two types of fire jar one's a
protective barrier for him to protect
his face from the fire and the heat and
one's the gel we actually set fire to
bins on fire obviously feels hot
different ways different methods of
doing it he will be warm he'll be
nervous
but everything's gonna be safe and happy
this is a very strange feeling this is
very strange because this is not my hand
it's too big to be on my hand it's too
gnarly to be my hand and yet
i look at it
and it's reacting like my hand because
this is really flexible yeah obviously
when your arm's out and it's on fire any
problems we'll be there we'll put you
out all right if you don't like it
raise your hand up and put it straight
out there
happy happy
let's do it
[Music]
i'm i'm not feeling nervous yet i don't
know if i should be you've been great at
reassuring me this is 100 fine there's
so many
layers between
where the fire is going to be because
you won't be able to feel it you'll go
oh look i'm on fire don't because it's
still hot you're gonna have to go well
and you've got your own fireproof suit
on absolutely
right so
what order do we go in
basically we've special effects here
they're gonna put some accelerant on
here we're gonna ignite your arm yep i'm
gonna count one two three i want you to
take a really big breath i'm gonna hand
over the special effects you're gonna
put
accelerant on your arms i'm gonna punch
this gentleman who's gonna ignite you
again any problems lift this arm up two
fireman come in put you straight out i'm
gonna be here with you at all times
making sure you're okay don't breathe
until co2 is on and off yes all right
just about there
yep
you ready to do it say three days breath
okay
two three four five six seven eight
ignite 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19.
can
look at me happy yeah happy
that was very strange
all right
i think we should get you re-changed yep
rehearse rehearse rehearse then do the
full button all right yeah everybody
happy with that yeah cool let's do it
that's all right
[Music]
i'm gonna say are you ready ready
six seven eight nine ten
eleven yeah turn around
just once and then go
put it out and action
really uncomfortable is about half the
size useful good
feeling comfy you know it works
suddenly gained
three sizes in every direction but i
wouldn't worry about it when you're on
fire yep no one's gonna really give up
[Music]
i'd like one more rehearsal please i
want to block that through one more time
so it's absolutely locked in my head
okay and i think that's me actually
rehearsing not me wanting to put off the
moment because all the nerves just
kicked in
walking away
first position deep breath
ignite
ready action
do you hate me ah yeah i do that's
really unpleasant
but yeah given given the
ah thanks for that
give him the choice
i'm not pulling punches no i wouldn't
ask you to because if you do it might
not be safe i hear that laughing
eyes nose everywhere cool
okay jenna come on there's no going back
now
keep that together
really breathe slowly chill out relax
we're going for it now
[Music]
so
walking away okay deep breath first
position hold your breath ignite him
like that
i got an email from tommy and jp at in
camera asking if i want to do some
actual real world pyrotechnic effects
like in the movies which is what you do
yes yeah so we brought a selection of
materials that we show you some
techniques that we use to create
miniature pyrotechnics for films yeah
all right what are we going to use we're
going to be using a combination of
powder effects no flammable liquids or
anything like that yeah yeah no gas no
squeeze
because i got this question no no no
definitely not especially not indoors no
no no
is that meant to have no that's not good
um okay would you mind if we cut we
should really check that
okay but look i i think this is leaking
[Music]
okay
thank you very much
[Laughter]
wow
honestly my heart rate at this point it
that's the moment where we got very very
real there we go right
that's an actual flamethrower
wow
and we cut into that
yep yeah
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
well that's good well done thank you
everyone
[Applause]
right i'm gonna shower